hello in this video we'll talk about
antioxidants which are substances that
prevent oxidation
the loss of electron is known as
oxidation process and as a result of
oxidation free radicals could be
generated which are electron hungry
species they can literally snatch
electron from any other molecules
but antioxidants are those molecules
which can donate electron to these
reactive oxygen species
and
thereby coming them down saving our body
from their harmful effect
so let's talk about how reactive oxygen
species are generated
they can be generated
under physiological or pathological
circumstances
under normal circumstances when we are
breathing under cellular respiration
ross can be generated in mitochondria
in the electron transport chain
we know that electrons are relayed and
ultimately that electron is accepted by
an electron acceptor which is oxygen
and that leads to production of h2o
simultaneously proton is pumped out and
it creates a proton gradient and that
gradient is utilized to generate atp
with the help of atp synthesis in line
now
let me tell you
if
oxygen receives four electron it would
be converted into two molecules of water
and that's okay
but
due to some circumstances if oxygen
receives
two electrons
one electron then it becomes
superoxide radical
if it receives two electrons then it
becomes
hydrogen peroxide if it receives three
electron it becomes hydroxyl radical
all of these are pretty dangerous
for our body
now let me tell you that
several cell types in our body such as
dendritic cell macrophages which are
immune cells
they use ros
to combat pathogens
they
use ros to kill the pathogens or create
membrane damage to these pathogens so
ross is not that bad
but there are a lot of harmful effects
of ros because ross can snatch electron
from the membrane that leads to charge
imbalance in the membrane and that
creates a free radical cascade in the
membrane this is called as lipid
peroxidation
and this leads to damage of the membrane
so cellular level of injury can happen
when there is too much of ross
other than that these reactive oxygen
species can steal
from enzymes
and can alter their functionality
it can also create dna damage by
stealing electron from the dna
so overall all of these reactive oxygen
species are pretty nasty but our body
can possibly fight back
these
harmful effects
by scavenging mechanisms so there are
two type of defense mechanism which are
utilized by our body
one is an enzymatic mechanism and
another is a non-enzymatic defense
system
in enzymatic defense system there are a
bunch of enzymes which combat ross and
in non-enzymatic defense system there
are several vitamins which are really
good antioxidants which we can obtain
via our diet
other than that there is glutathione
chelating agents like metal proteins
which can also combat ross and prevent
harmful effects of
ross
so having a
balanced diet
combining several foods is really
important especially
food that are enriched in vitamin a such
as carrot bell pepper
mutton liver
sweet potatoes are really important
things that are enriched in
vitamin e such as several grains
olives kiwi these are good
now vitamin c is a potent antioxidant
and the key sources of vitamin
c is bell pepper lemon orange guava
brussels sprout cauliflower or even kiwi
other than these substances
we can get antioxidants from berries
and several spices like turmeric
cinnamon etc so
so far we have discussed that we can
consume antioxidants by having
their input from our diet
but other than diet
we have several defense mechanism
embedded in our body itself and these
are enzymatic defense against reactive
oxygen species
so they also work like an antioxidant
because they neutralize these free
radicals first and foremost we should
talk about superoxide dismutase which
converts superoxide radical into oxygen
and hydrogen peroxide which is less
harmful
anyway hydrogen peroxide gets further
converted to water
with the help of the enzyme glutathione
peroxidase
which literally takes
electron from reduced glutathione and
give it to the hydrogen peroxide radical
but in this process glutathione is
oxidized himself
now oxidized glutathione need to be
replenished and it need to be reduced so
that is done by glutathione reductase
and this process involves nadph
so this is enzymatic defense system
against reactive oxygen species
now
good source of glutathione
includes spinach broccoli brussels
sprout or asparagus so we need to ensure
we
include these things in our diet in
order to combat ross
now let me tell you having adequate
amount of antioxidant can slow down
aging
not only that
ross has some bright side as well
now ross is not really that bad when
produced in a very low level
but what are the circumstances when ross
is produced at a manageable level
exercise
when we do exercise very low level of
ross is
produced
and that has benefits let me tell you
how
now generally when ross is produced in
our body our defense mechanism try to
combat cross
by
neutralizing them
now when we do exercise every day little
bit of ross is generated this is kind of
tuning our ross defense system
now next time whenever there is high
level of uh
ros exposure from let's say
pollutants or let's say pesticides or
even from the uv then our body can
combat ross in a way better fashion than
before
that means small small exposure every
day
makes us more prepared to fight the
battle
so moral of the story we need to eat
healthy we need to do exercise every
time in order to protect our body from
ross mediated damages so i hope this
video was useful if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to like share and subscribe hit that
bell icon for getting notification you
can connect to me via social media all
the links are provided in my description
you can connect you can find me in
social media via this name thanks for
listening see you in the next video